les dents comme ceux ci et les
transforment en cela les publicités sont
nombreuses et attrayante à la télévision
sur les réseaux sociaux des entreprises
offrent de redresser vos dents pour une
fraction du prix
l'une d'elles smiled avec club est en
pleine expansion
en plus d'offrir ses services par
internet elle possède plus de 300
boutiques dans le monde dont trois dans
la province
ça nous inquiète de voir que des
produits authentiques qui sont vendus
sur un marché où il ya pas justement de
diagnostic de bienfaits le principe est
simple un client peut se rendre dans une
boutique pour effectuer un scan de ses
dents ou bien faire une empreinte à la
maison dans les deux cas un
professionnel existant ce programme la
série des ligneurs ensuite livré à
domicile le suivi se fait tous les 90
jours par l'envoi de photographies par
internet mouscron donne c'est un service
on offre un service médical une nouvelle
tendance qui préoccupe l'association des
orthodontistes du québec en raison de
l'absence de suivi en personne toutes
lettres médicale a eu son lot de risques
ou de complications ou d'effets
secondaires l'orthodontie s'échappe pas
perdre de gens sic par exemple s'assurer
que les déplacements des daims vont
faire en sorte qu'ils repas de perte de
chance et certaines situations si c'est
pas bien contrôlé peuvent même aller
jusqu'à perte de da on aimerait bien
qu'ils aient une professionnelle la
santé qui sont impliqués dans ce
processus là adaptons napoli de
confirmation que cet alcool
club 3 dentiste orthodontiste reconnue
au québec travaille avec eux ils peuvent
communiquer avec le client la compagnie
ajoute que le traitement est sécuritaire
et efficace
les difficultés sont rare puisqu'elle ne
traite que les problèmes léger à modéré
mais advenant un problème on est en
train d'obtenir de contactez-nous moment
pour savoir si shawn heins c'est un
phénomène qui est tellement rsa si
l'association mène sa petite enquête
interne
l'ordre des dentistes du québec qui a
pour mission d'assurer la qualité des
services en médecine dentaire ne se
prononcent pas pour l'instant il n'est
pas de l'intention de l'ordre des
dentistes de commenter pour le moment
les services de la nature de ceux
offerts par ce mal d'arrêts club au
public québécois l'ordre ajoute nous ne
sommes pas en mesure de confirmer ou non
si une telle enquête est en cours
présentement en raison des règles de
confidentialité qui régissent l'ordre en
matière d' enquête du syndic
aux etats unis les critiques sont
nombreuses l'association américaine des
orthodontistes a reçu des plaintes dans
de nombreux états et les mets une alerte
aux consommateurs concernant
l'orthodoxie à domicile sur son site
depuis cinq ans mme haidar club à
redresser les dents de plus de 750 mille
personnes les commentaires sur les
différentes plateformes d'opinion sont
mitigés une tendance qui porte à
réflexion
ici alexandra duval radio canada québec